das ist wirklich ein riesenschritt für
die wissenschaft ein hubschrauber hätte
auf dem mars ganz andere möglichkeiten
der erkundung neuer erkenntnisse könnten
uns tatsächlich im wochentakt zu fliegen
klicks um science-fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierendes
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst er nichts herzlich
willkommen er könnte vielleicht das
erste menschengemachte fluggerät auf
einem fremden planeten werden ein
kleiner autonome maß hubschrauber der
nasa der schon im kommenden jahr mit dem
nächsten mars-rover zum roten planeten
aufbrechen sondern und die ersten flug
test waren jetzt tatsächlich erfolgreich
der mini helikopter hat bewiesen dass er
auch in der dünnen atmosphäre des mars
abheben und fliegen kann er wiegt nur
1,8 kilogramm und liefert mit
unglaublichen 3000
wirklich ab denn damit schafft der maz
und schrauber der nasa fast zehnmal so
viele umdrehungen wie ein gewöhnlicher
hubschrauber hier auf der erde zu seiner
hohen leistungen kommen noch die
gegenläufig rotierenden rotoren das
alles soll dann flüge auf dem mars
ermöglichen und das unter den dort
gegebenen bedingungen die wirklich nicht
ohne sind konkret meine ich damit zum
beispiel die dünne atmosphäre
deren dichte nur etwa ein prozent der
erdatmosphäre entspricht diese galt es
also für den flug test auf der erde
nachzustellen eine gar nicht so einfache
aufgabe für das nasa forschungsteams
dazu die projektmanagerin mini auch um
diese bewegungen auf der erde zu
bekommen müsste man einen testflug in 30
kilometern höhe zurückführen
doch dies würde ein gewöhnlicher
hubschrauber gar nicht packen denn laut
der nasa experten und expertinnen liegt
der höhenrekord eines hubschraubers der
hier auf der erde fliegt bei rund zwölf
kilometern 40.000 fuß und so haben die
experten und expertinnen für den flug
test eine etwa acht meter große
vakuumkammer entwickelt und darin eine
art mars atmosphäre erzeugt dafür wurde
zunächst die komplette luft
herausgepumpt und dann kohlendioxid
hinzugefügt und zwar so viel wie es eben
der zusammensetzung der marsatmosphäre
entspricht doch das war nur eine der
vielen herausforderungen für die nasa
fachleute dazu teddy sein epos um das
liegen auf dem mars realistisch zu
simulieren müssen wir auch zwei drittel
der ert schwerkraft entfernen die lösung
dazu war ein wirklich spezielles
aufhänger system
es hatte die aufgabe einen teil der last
mitzutragen und zwar den flugbewegungen
so konnte das nasa forschungsteam genau
analysieren wie viel auftrieb notwendig
ist damit der hubschrauber auf dem mars
abheben kann und tatsächlich der
testflug war erfolgreich insgesamt
zweimal in der vakuumkammer ab und
schwebte einige zentimeter über dem
boden ein entscheidender schritt denn
nur durch diese erfolgreich absolvierten
testflüge konnten die fachleute ihre
modelle und vorherigen tests bestätigen
dazu die nasa wir brauchten nur diese
fünf zentimeter höhe um alle nötigen
daten zu sammeln sie bestätigen dass
unser maß helikopter autonom in einer
mars atmosphäre fliegen kann
es war ein großartiger erster flug und
seine premiere auf dem mars wird
wahrscheinlich schon sehr bald erfolgen
denn der helikopter soll schon im
kommenden jahr zu seiner reise zum mars
aufbrechen und zwar als teil der
geplanten mission mars two thousand and
i der nasa hier soll ein rover zum roten
planeten gebracht werden der mit chaos
city vergleichbar ist der 2020 rover
wird nicht nur geologische
untersuchungen des mars bodens vornehmen
und den roten planeten auf seine
bewohnbarkeit für eine zukünftige
menschliche besiedlung untersuchen
sondern auch ausschau nach leben auf dem
mars halten planmäßig soll der mars
helikopter im februar 2021 auf dem roten
planeten landen und zwar gut geschützt
im bauch des mars rovers sein erster
flug ist einige monate später geplant
und das wird dann wohl eine premiere
werden denn bisher waren immer nur
fahrende oder stationäre systeme an der
erkundung des mars beteiligt zunächst
sondern nur kurze flüge absolvieren mit
einer dauer von jeweils 90 sekunden
damit könnte er einige hundert meter
weit kommen das ist schon was doch die
nasa denkt schon an größere modelle sie
dann folgen könnten denn klar ist dass
diese vogelperspektive
weitere spannende erkenntnisse liefern
könnte dazu nasa mitarbeiter thomas zu
buchen
die fähigkeit zu sehen was hinter dem
nächsten hügel liegt ist für künftige
maß forscher entscheiden
denn so könnten hubschrauber als eine
art speer auf fremden planeten unterwegs
sein und natürlich auch orte an fliegen
die von land fahrzeugen nicht erreicht
werden um den bedingungen auf dem mars
zu trotzen tüfteln die dasa übrigens
schon seit sommer 2003
denn an diesem projekt so verfügt der
mini hubschrauber auch über solarzellen
um seine batterien zu laden und zu dem
auch über einen heitz mechanismus
schließlich wird es in den kalten
nächten wirklich bitter kalt kälter als
im sibirischen winter an den polen
betragen die temperaturen sogar bis zu
minus 120 grad celsius weil die
funksignale von der erde zum mars
mehreren minuten unterwegs sein werden
kann er nicht mehr gesteuert werden
somit ist der autonom und lenkt seine
flugbahn selbst er interpretiert die
befehle von der bodenstation und richtet
seine flugbahn danach aus wahnsinn das
kann wirklich die mars forschung
entscheidend nach vorne treiben finden
wir dort leben oder leben wir bald auf
dem mars dass es dieses video hier
draufklicken anschauen und doktor watson
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran